what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we are going to
start up the show arcane who got so many
requests for this don't know if people
are going to watch our reaction or not
but hey if you're here please hit that
like button mean the world if you can
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next arcane episode is up as
always full length watch long is where
you sync up with the time code for any
of the shows that you see here on the
channel or about our patreon page there
are plenty of shows over there where for
most of them you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included the boyz at prepper editing
down the highlights for this one and
lastly i gotta say this is this is like
prequel story stuff to league of legends
we don't know league of legends just
gotta be fully up front of course we're
like we've heard of it and we've been
familiarized with like certain clips and
trailers in the past but we by no means
know the story of it i'm not gonna bs
you through that i've been
reassured by countless people and that
that doesn't matter we can still go and
enjoy the show i'm sure it's like more
beneficial for people who are just
letting you know up front that there's
like easter eggs or something we're not
gonna notice that okay we're going in
blind we haven't even seen a trailer for
this show uh have you nope
i have not seen a trailer for this show
going purely off of the
the harassment in the comments
which makes it seem like so many people
will watch hype wrestling
all right guys let's do it
[Music]
whoa i'm hooked
all it took was 10 seconds
wow
i already have so much chills oh my god
i got like cute smokes rubbing down my
body
what is this
oh
wow
[Music]
so much gravitas
i feel like i'm watching a new villainy
kingdom amongst the horrors there that
was such a desolate and striking intro
my goodness yeah that was gripping
[Music]
he's so beautiful
i'll get it no
powder look at me what did i tell you
i'm ready that's right
so you can do parkour come on
wow yeah perspective
warp
guys this looks important
the real jackpot
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
what have you guys done
wow
the camera work on the show is insane
damn
i feels so goddamn visceral i love it
love it what the hell happened back
there
i don't know i didn't do anything it was
the sandwich
how about you share a little taste of
your treasure there and we'll call it
even no no no we worked too hard
just a taste
just
oh nice
ouch
oh they're all getting agent smith
[Music]
oh
man
this day's turning out all right after
all
oh no no it's not let me shake you come
back here
so blood yeah
oh no
this has such a great swashbuckling
adventurous spirit to it man you folks
need anything
leave us
you sure about that
send it to me like piss off
[Music]
you don't seem to listen a bit of advice
don't threaten the guy who pours the
drinks that is good advice
[Laughter]
we stay out of piltover's business why
they've got plenty while we're down here
scraping together coins when did you get
so comfortable living in someone else's
shadow
ooh bold words everyone out i'm about to
beat this poor man
you're gonna have to lay low for a bit
understand
okay we're gonna be fine right
i'll take care of it
[Music]
you know what milo
you're right there's a bunch of things
powder just can't do you don't have to
tell me twice
but i complain about everything what no
come on she missed that
right time to walk away
oh crap
uh-oh that's not good
well hello
what is the air made of down here
some trench of trash attacked one of the
buildings in the academy district
but you already knew that we're looking
for the cartridge got a description yeah
it's exactly who you're picturing in
that thick head of yours
lovely chap you bro
clever you know this cross the line
upstairs was anyone heard a building was
blown to bits what do you think maybe
you don't seem to grasp how serious this
is if i don't put someone behind bars
tonight the next time i come down here
oh no
he's gonna go i'm sorry grayson
but i can't offer up my own people
[ __ ] i ruined everything
i always do nobody said that
no
just that you were twice the person at
half my age
you heard them
these were in my pocket
they're from the apartment
what are they i don't know should we
show vander no
let's keep this our little secret
milo's wrong powder
you're stronger than you think
this city's gonna respect us
or crumble
be crushed by the top side
the kids
it was their fault
the explosion in the upper city
that was them
yeah
the top siders are up in arms looking
for him
van der's in trouble
that guy looks bad
our timeline has moved up
it's almost ready
oh no what are you gonna do
feeding time
oh oh no
[Music]
stabilizing
is that rat gonna defeat the cat
[Music]
i think the rat's gonna defeat the cat i
think that rat is about to hulk
the f out
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
but the kitty
someone just volunteered
[Music]
only the first episode boom that was
[ __ ] great so cool
[Music]
so that was great
punch
oh man
let's talk about it
i thought that was great it had such a
wonderful array of
tone and genre splicing and
there there was a portion i i think it
was the first time when they were
getting caught when it's like there's
the
obviously as we're getting acquainted
with the world we'll pick up on the
names of all the the cities and
locations you know
and uh how the cities and all that are
separated by the the classism and
whatnot
um but in terms of an introductory
episode i was so impressed with just how
it seamlessly weaved in and out of so
much like from its opening
sequence teasing of what's to come
this it really felt like out of a denim
villa new film of this like
haunting desolate
uh just insanely dramatic tone poem of a
sequence it was like no dialogue at all
but i was so swept up in it
and then to go to this like adventurous
swashbuckling engaging sci-fi
aspect of the world there was a portion
of the action scenes where i was just so
caught up in being dazzled and the
wonder of the filmmaking that i just
started like shedding a tear which never
happens to me i'm just like i'm just so
moved by how great and moving the
filmmaking itself is that it was just
reminding me of so much of a great
hodgepodge of of like i was getting
qualities of like when spielberg
directed uh uh the what was the and
adventures of tintin when he directed
tintin but had a bit of like
a phil lord and chris miller vibe to it
along with like a brad bird animation
style aesthetic as well
and it's just a cool world to get
encompassed and enamored with and it had
a great introductory to the the whole
characters of our main protagonists are
going to be watching with violet and
powder and i actually like that we don't
know the
the league of legends world because it
makes it more interesting here
and uh yeah so that was like the basic
thoughts summed up in like a minute and
a half for me but john what did you
think so far for the first episode yeah
i was very dazzled and gripped by this i
mean
the animation off the bat is just so
expressive and lucid in the way that
they orchestrate these camera techniques
through the animation i thought was
incredibly impressive both and just like
the little jitters they use to highlight
action as well as the changes in
perspective like you know you're doing
all sorts of stuff that you couldn't do
with a real camera but also evoking the
types of shots and the types of looks
you would get out of a real camera and
switching between them
you know seamlessly in one shot a lot of
the time and uh yeah it really enhanced
that punchy swashbuckling
adventure but also um intense energy and
yeah it really swept me up in you know
the adventure being along with these
kids you know having the fun of the
heist but then also revealing you know
the the bigger scope of how the world
this world works um you know and it's
i'm
curious to see how it builds upon this
and becomes more and more unique because
you know like this is the type of story
that we have seen but it's so
beautifully
hewn especially through this art style
that
to me hearkens to fantasy
and like steampunk and fantasy sci-fi
especially
um where you have this almost dual
approach where it looks like
2d
paintings but also 3d and coming from a
studio that makes video games and who
has been known for making you know
shorts and trailers that are very
cinematic
throughout this i was sitting here going
wow this really does feel like the
combination of you know like a narrative
cinematic piece but also like a cut
scene like you know there's certain
little flourishes and energetic visual
elements that reminded me of a video
game cut scene in a good way uh not in
like oh the cg could be better kind of
way
and yeah i i got incredibly just swept
up in the whole entire scope of it is
just so beautiful to look at but also
really engaging on an emotional level on
a you know plot level i can't wait to
see how this all grows and continues uh
yeah i was i was very enthralled yeah i
was i i would say like dazzled would be
the word for me uh on this particular
experience
it's the the world that they have here
i don't know i mean you're saying that
what do you mean that we've seen
something like this because i can't
think of anything like this that i've
seen before other things that it evokes
i i can't really think of something
where i'm like
i don't know this this seems very unique
to me well you know like gang of uh of
kids who come from a rough environment
rough background who are making their
way in the world coming of age they've
got like a strong protector figure
there's a greater oh that's what i mean
by the character dynamics yeah like
these kinds of stories but this world
that they've drawn here is quite unique
and is quite you know vibrant and alive
i mean yeah there are other aesthetic
schools that are clearly influencing it
um so you know to see how the story
evolves into something truly unique to
this world that is so unique is
something i'm curious to see but you
know at the outset
just introducing everybody laying
everything out you know setting the
stage i i yeah it was dazzled as as you
said yeah it's like while there's like
familiar archetypes in here i think the
voice work of everyone is perfect
everyone is perfect it feels alive i
don't feel like i'm watching
it it feels like cinematic you know what
i mean it doesn't it's like there's
often uh there there's often a big
divide between like an animated movie
and animated shows and every once in a
while like there are some great animated
shows don't get me wrong there's some
like beautiful animated shows but more
often than not it's like no that's a
show
and then there's movies
and this has such a cinematic approach
to it like the the the emotions that it
just generates from it from almost every
single sequence here
it's
if i'm like i wish i was watching this
on the big screen that's kind of just
the vibe that i get
almost from beginning to end and i think
in terms of plot mechanisms
you know it's like the way they have
that opening sequence where they're
pulling off the highest and then [ __ ]
goes wrong
i wasn't expecting it to uh become such
a tension-filled
uh moment towards the end of like what
they did is actually gonna have severe
consequences because a lot of the times
in stories like this it's kind of like
fun heist going wrong but it's you know
sure it'll factor in and it's going to
be important
but i wasn't expecting the stakes to
become so
heavy
by the end of it where you got the
what's the same vanderbilt bander when
he got bander and he's being
interrogated by the cops and he's
obviously friends with one of them or
enforcers and he's friends with one of
them and then you're learning that
actually what they did wasn't just some
like kids messed up you know whatever
give them the slap on the wrist here but
he'll take care of it it's not just some
learning lesson for them like this is
gonna have drastic consequences for how
the plot unfolds it's linking to the
prologue at hand
and i can just only imagine the weight
the the emotional turmoil that that's
going to cause for
our characters the specifically violet
and powder for the actions they did and
how that went wrong and already like a
character like powder who has this
journey that you can already see of
someone who has to learn to become you
know more confident in herself has to
develop courage be be more brave you
know starts off on this really
frightened stage
and has to find herself and the strength
within
while looking up to this violet
character who's also learning how to be
a leader and not really understanding
the consequences of being a leader like
that usually a leader has this like
responsibility bestowed upon them that
they never quite asked for
and that's the good position she's in
it's like you know she's just kind of
done her own thing and she has people
who look up to her
she never really asked for this but now
that she has a responsibility it's her
responsibility she has to handle it she
has to take care of it and be aware of
it
and
i like that you have not just great
world building and not just amazing
action sequences it's complemented so
well by
having an attention to detail on the
characters to the point where you're
like oh i'm also really invested in
their journey and i'm concerned for them
when shit's about to really hit the fan
based off of how their heist went wrong
it's not just some funny
thing that went wrong that led to a cool
action scene
it's it's going to have severe
consequences it seems like for the whole
underground world
because they hate because vander wants
to protect them because they are just
kids
and so it's already managed because the
thing is when you have a world this big
it's easy to make it feel impersonal
because there were times i was like oh
[ __ ] i gotta have my attention i'm
spanish i gotta have like my focus game
on because i'm learning a bunch of new
words and a bunch of new things that
i've never this is all but this is
really intricate it's very involved
and i imagine if you play the game or
something maybe it makes it easier to to
latch on to everything but i was like oh
this is this is very like this is like a
a more uh micro version of watching like
a dune or something
like i gotta pay attention to all the
sci-fi layers here
uh but yeah i thought they managed to
capture uh something personal while also
giving us something grand in scale
and so yeah i thought it was smart
having that prologue at the top because
you know shit's gonna get very dark so
then it's very red
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's yeah it's very it it like you
said it is extremely
expressive but it's just like there's
nothing
in frame that doesn't get a little extra
personality it's like if you sit and
look at like all the characters have
their own little mannerisms and the you
know
it it really feels like they spared no
expense to make this work yeah
yeah it's energetic it's eclectic it's i
loved it i thought i was uh
the first few minutes i was like oh [ __ ]
i am going to love this show
tell me more yes
the first few minutes i i just i just
knew it and of course the tease of the
bill and that's to come uh but
yeah man rough rat street rat let's get
going let's get going arcane thank you
guys so much for recommending this show
and um yeah
subscribe hit that bell hit that like
button
that's my list
i'm gonna shout out today rosa parra i
feel like a this could be a show that
you could sit down and watch with your
kids
and in some ways you can't remind me the
violet character gotta deal with a bunch
of rascals who are not really listening
to you you gotta live such a tough
tough life
and you gotta be get your hands dirty
once in a while to take care of them
they look up to you and maybe sometimes
you get a temper but i feel like you're
probably better at controlling your
temper than this violet person but
either way
i feel like it's a good family bonding
show for you guys i think you guys
should watch it together you should be
reviewing it
get them a latin numbers up you know
what i mean he's a critic because you
guys i'm not just critic
so yeah i mean i was just looking
through our list and i was like
easily rose is the violet oh absolutely
out of anyone left i'd follow you into
any fire
a robbery any fire you know or anything
would you want into a fire because maybe
there's something valuable in the fire
or or a person worth saving she's not a
thief maybe she just told me to walk
into the fire
such a good leader
because she's so commanding and and and
she knows what she's doing
she must have a good reason for me to
walk you know frozen very differently
rosa i would do anything for you
i'll find a fire right right okay we're
done we're done now we're done
[Music]